president Donald Trump is reportedly
looking for ways to retaliate against
Beijing for the deadly virus that
emanated from China they could have
stopped it but they didn't it's
something that is gonna have to be dealt
with White House managers are said to be
meeting to discuss options that
according to the Washington Post include
a lawsuit seeking damages or one of the
president's preferred penalties new
tariffs on Wall Street Stocks plunged
over tariffs fears there's little doubt
the virus began in China's Wuhan
province that's the global pandemic has
turned a complex relationship between
two world powers into a simple won
outright rivalry been stopped at the
Trump has been fuming about China saying
China either knowingly spread the virus
or failed to warn the world of a
pandemic that has stalled the US economy
and dimmed his re-election prospects
well they've done it the US and China
have had complicated interaction since
the handshake in 1972 between President
Richard Nixon and Mao Zedong that began
a profitable but troubled relationship
the state of Missouri
isn't waiting for the federal government
it's already suing China for economic
losses and there are private suits
including a class-action suit by Florida
businesses that seeks reparations on
behalf of thousands of people China
calls this suits political farce
distributing a cartoon video that
accuses the u.s. of failing to protect
its people for months
we said it was dangerous now in China
and in the US the prospect of new
economic penalties leads relations
between the superpowers at their lowest
point in the 21st century john Hendren
al jazeera Chicago